hey guys back at Roseanne's kitchen
table with ben mankiewicz i am dave
rubin as pretty professional a nice job
uh so i wanted to talk to you about
saying that I think about a lot and uh I
sort of had an ongoing debate with a
couple friends with you know where the
political world were in the talk world
we give our opinions between our
opinions were doing videos blah blah
blah uh and I sense this thing happening
where people are just constantly having
their opinions reinforced only following
people on Twitter that they agree with
people only watching videos of people
that they agree with if you're if you're
on the right you watch Fox all the time
you never see anything on MSNBC blah
blah blah not even that they're that
different anymore but that that's all
other topic um and I got into a pretty
heavy fight with a friend of mine about
some political stuff recently and then
it was making me think can you really be
friends with some of that you're
fighting with politically now I think
the answers yes and I i love debate um
but i think a lot of people aren't able
to do it anymore i think there's
actually something happening because of
the internet and all this [ __ ] that were
walking around with typing on the people
are starting to really just kind of
section off into their own little things
and not get debate there anything there
any better agree with me there people
blame for this it's not just that we've
become people on the far left people on
the far right that has an app and Fox
and MSNBC aren't the same MSNBC's got a
lot may have a lot of problems and but
they're basically trying to give you
information encouraging you to take in
that information Fox literally doesn't
want you to read mail holder network
television designed they were they
encourage you not to read don't pick up
that paper yeah don't do it I'll tell
you what it says yeah right so uh we had
this debate on a podcast that the the
jack and I do you know when we started
the young turks are our goal was to talk
about politics half-time in jlo's ass
half the time and then we went to war in
Iraq we couldn't do it so now we did
this podcast old-school retrying restore
JLo that yeah right so aidonia went
anywhere yeah so anyway we uh uh last
night we were doing the show uh we
discussed like that is you could easily
have been friends with people who
weren't on your side politically in the
1970s and the 1980s because there was
meaning
into the eighties not far that he hates
as I started to change because there was
meaningful conversation about ideas
Congress was full not entirely full of
people who had ideas and they debated
those ideas uh now as we see time and
time again it is not full of people with
ideas in any way in fact one whole party
doesn't have any ideas their whole point
is no no we've had too many ideas are
idea now is to just stop you know top
stop stop stop stop we real quick I so
Congress did get sworn in today attract
a and as I was watching it I was
following along on Twitter everything I
kept thinking what a profoundly
uninspiring group of people there wasn't
anyone that I was like this guy like I
did that it probably goes to exactly
what your point is an hour you continue
you know it's all right i mean i just it
it was you know in in the 1970s there
were real liberals in Congress yeah with
george mcgovern frank church Birch Bayh
and these guys argued with conservatives
who thought they had some good ideas
right and conservatives who were like
well obviously have to take care of
people some people need help we gotta do
there was a there's a role for
government it was a debate about what
the role government was going to be that
those guys were completely purged from
republican party they're gone yeah and
meanwhile the democratic party and
really sort of out of you could say
necessity if you want to be kind or just
cold calculating uh politics really
abandoned that part of the party and now
we have sort of uh you know of a
corporate of crazy tea party a
corporatist right wing in a slightly
less awkward is left when you left left
center uh and the you know and then
there's like an almost before and you
point to like four guys right now who
sort of a Bernie Sanders everyone's
prisoner but they don't have power you
know back up I'll be wrapped in 22
seconds that but the death of coming
combining the 24-hour news cycle with
sort of Reagan's uh the aggressive
purging of all government regulation and
minimizing a government and that that
happens with the 24-hour news cycle and
the birth of the right wing echo chamber
all sort of come together at this time
at the exact moment maybe become maybe
they contributed to this with the death
of unions in America and as corrupt as
some unions were right they had a seat
at the table and they argued on behalf
of American workers they're not there's
nobody to take there is no one at the
table now and that makes a difference
that's why it was important and now
we're sort of suffering the consequences
that and part of that is is that we've
now with no meaningful ideas being
espoused by leaders were left to being
disciples of sean hannity and it all
only can use her on the same sentence
sean hannity for the purpose this
conversation and rachel maddow once 50
times smarter than the other one right
but that's what we get and there's no
mixing but i don't blame people for that
i've been a process and a and leadership
that is totally broken right so how do
you deal with it in your I wouldn't
personal I was a significant right we
could do it yet really i mean i don't i
say that i have some I have friends who
were Republicans they they continue to
hold on to this are they're not they're
like oh no I'm not like them but you are
like that right like you know you can't
at some point you know a man it you know
you like Jesse Helms in in the 1980s it
was like you're at the years you're
standing in a room with jesse helms and
Strom Thurmond you can't do it you gotta
leave that room right you gotta say I
agree with you guys on some things but
yeah you're hideous racist yeah I see
that party and that's the thing about
the internet that I think is
particularly interesting so like for
example with the Middle East stuff
obviously Jake and I pretty serious
disagreements he's my my boss of that
the network that I work for and people
always comment in the thing all they
must hate each other they must want to
kill each other and actually were
friends we play basketball together we
have healthy debates going back and
forth about it and it's like I feel like
that's disappearing but what did you you
brought up the Israel and the
Palestinian issue whether there should
be a Palestinian state and that all by
itself that's still an idea like when
you and Jake argue you were literally
arguing about ideas yeah you didn't
argue he wasn't saying Israel's I hate
Israel just saying o Israel has a right
to exist and they must remain there we
must do all we can to defend that said
what we do about this and not and you
thought they're being attacked and they
have a reason to defend themselves and I
think they have it is
least it was an idea as opposed to just
the kind of argument that rush we are
having in the side we get back argument
that rush limbaugh has always wanted us
that yeah I've he's telling you got a
rapper how do we get out of that because
that's I mean that's why I'm trying to
do the show the way I do it to have a
little more of that discussion and have
it about the ideas not about just the
clamoring but I feel like there's just
so little of it we need people to talk
about ideas and the only people gonna do
it are Democrats to really talk about
ideas the only people I thought would
but they're not they're not they're not
they've given up so it's incredibly
don't know and hopefully things cycle
back where that sort of really dynamic
creative leaders with ideas somehow come
back into vogue and we don't get hung up
on whether they didn't there whether
they they did or didn't pay their
nannies taxes at 25 years ago right well
that's it or or whether they slept with
the nanny cuz who gives a [ __ ] yeah do
you guys think we should have more
public debates about ideas and are any
of you right wingers that want to be
friends with Ben if so a bigger the day
somebody if you wicked eh i have
resumption from Republican press then
they and I'm always the liberal they
like yeah I know you have to believe
that yeah all right let us know in the
comments right down below